hey you guys time for another movie
review
have another kind of interesting one uh
for you today i mean all of the ones i
talk about are interesting but you know
this one's interesting because
it's another one that i feel like
particularly in art film circles like
back in the 90s was sort of like all the
rage but i feel like subsequently it's
maybe been forgotten about a little bit
which is kind of a shame because uh this
is one weird ass movie and i like i said
i do kind of feel like
people like me that
back in the 90s when i was in my early
20s and was going to a lot of these art
films and renting them and i was really
into them and stuff i kind of feel like
this was one that a lot of people were
talking about
and i don't know i just kind of feel
like not that many people talk about it
anymore
this came out in
1995 and it's called the city of lost
children now this is actually a
co-production of france it's in french
france germany and spain
and it was directed written and directed
i believe by mark carro and jean-pierre
janae
who also did delicatessen a little bit
later and they also did emily which was
uh obviously i think that came out in
2000 2001 something like that and was
like a massive international success now
if you've seen emily you might get a
little bit of an idea
of what their style is but i will say i
really did like emily i haven't seen it
a long time i think i saw in the theater
but that one is a lot more light-hearted
and a lot more whimsical than city of
lost children city of lost children has
whimsy in it as well but it's much much
darker
and it's kind of i don't know it's more
akin to like some more terry gilliam
kind of stuff like if you liked brazil
and you haven't seen city of lost
children it's kind of like a similar
vibe uh this is also a very early
example of kind of like a steampunk sort
of aesthetic even though the story isn't
exactly the same as a steampunk type
story but the the visuals are very
reminiscent um very very steampunky in
that way
also
uh if you didn't know if you're a big
fan of the fallout games the game
designers uh cited this movie as one of
their major uh influences on the visuals
of the first fallout game but in
particular the second fallout game
fallout 2. so if you've seen the you
know the whole aesthetic of fallout 2
know that a lot of it came from the game
designers being really really into this
movie and like constantly having it
going on a loop and they actually paid
homage to some things that are going on
in this movie
so
yeah so like i said if you're into like
real surrealist because when i describe
the plot to you it's such as it is
it's gonna sound like i'm tripping balls
because there's a lot going on in this
and it's just completely bizarre
and i think like even famously at the
time like roger ebert who actually was
really into this movie but when he
reviewed it when it came out he's like
i'd be lying if i said i knew what the
[ __ ] was going on he's like if i said if
i thought that i understood the plot
it's not i've seen it a few times
because as i said back in the 90s when i
was in my 20s i kind of hung out with a
couple other people that were really
into
films and particularly like weird ass
films
and so we would like usually go to you
know the cheap theater to see them or
like rent them or whatever and this was
definitely one that was in heavy
rotation and a lot of people like talked
about mostly because i feel like the
plot of this isn't necessarily its
strength even though it's crazy as [ __ ]
which like i said i'll get into that in
a little bit but the visuals of this are
amazing just like the whole aesthetic of
it it's just so so imaginative and it's
just really it's just a beautiful
looking film also a beautiful sounding
film the score is amazing also which is
actually done by angelo batalimenti who
obviously works with david lynch a lot
he had blue velvet and all of that so
you know the score is very memorable the
visuals are very memorable you know just
the whole idea of it is so bizarre it's
almost kind of like i was listening to
um
like a long podcast where they were
talking about this movie i think it's
called chat the movies or something yeah
shot the movies and i was listening they
did like an hour-long podcast on this
movie and they were talking about like
one of the guys said something like well
you know if you liked edward
scissorhands or something like that or
tim burton stuff it's like this kind of
makes tim burton stuff look like amateur
hour which
totally i mean you can see where it's
the same kind of like surrealistic sort
of like aesthetic but this is like way
weirder this is like way the [ __ ] out
there as i said this is more like terry
gilliam type stuff so if you like terry
gilliam but you've never heard of this
movie or never seen it then definitely
give this one a watch because i think
it'll be like right in your wheelhouse
at the moment i watched it on amazon
prime
if you have amazon prime you can watch
it for free at least as of this
recording uh so i don't i'm sure it's
probably on some other streaming service
as well but that's where i watched it
and as i said i probably hadn't seen
this since
the late 90s i feel like i saw it a few
times back in the day
but hadn't really seen it since then so
i was kind of excited to like revisit it
for this series
so
okay let me see if i can
lay this out for you oh i want to say
too that if you it's
you know it's pretty much all french
actors but uh this is actually a very
early role for ron perlman
now ron perlman uh he kind of came i
think he was more like a stage actor so
this was one of his early film roles
and uh interestingly this movie is in
french ron perlman uh does not speak
french or he did not at this time he
might nowadays i don't know but he
didn't speak french at this time so he
basically just had he doesn't have a lot
of dialogue in this which we'll get into
like why that is and like what his
character is like so he did like learn
his few lines in french
but it's just kind of funny because yeah
he didn't speak french at all and he
said that he was like the only american
i feel like on the set so that must have
been a little bit weird but like i said
it kind of works with the whole uh the
whole
aesthetic of the movie and it kind of
works with the whole
you know sort of thing of his character
because he's kind of supposed to be
a bit a little bit not necessarily an
outsider but somebody that's like
different from everybody else in the
movie
okay so there's a bunch of stuff going
on in this movie now it's not
as i said it's kind of like surrealist
so it's not set in a specific
place or time
really
it's kind of like i don't know it's kind
of like a noir i want to say but
way more like fantastical it's not
science fiction necessarily it's more
like sci fantasy and like i said it's
very it's honestly like i said this
could be a long time ago it could be
post-apocalyptic it could be like
anything it could be anything or
anywhere it's just like taking place in
some
other place and some other time some
kind of like fantastical world that's
kind of like self-contained so you have
this
old guy who is a creation of a scientist
but we'll get into that this is going to
be very very complicated for me to
explain i'm already kind of sitting
there going oh my god how am i going to
explain this like a movie okay so
there's this old guy
uh named crunk
and
he you kind of initially think like he's
kind of like a mad scientist type
character but then you find out later
that he's actually the creation of a
scientist as i said we'll get into that
more later
now he's kind of like
i guess he was created without the
ability to dream
because he can't dream
this has made him age prematurely
so what he's decided to do
he has this kind of like mad scientist
lair type situation which is on this
oil rig type thing that's like in the
middle of there's like all this water
it's just like i said it's not any place
or time specifically
so he has this big lab set up this very
very steam punky lab everything has like
big gears and buttons and it's just it's
very very cool looking i mean the
production design the art direction and
this is just
amazing you don't have to really follow
the story you could just put this movie
on it's about two hours long and just
play music or something behind it and
just like be mesmerized by all the
visuals i mean it's cooler like if you
kind of know what's going on but you
totally don't have to know what's going
on i mean you could just it could just
be like a [ __ ] music video and just
be like wow wow look at that like look
at the sets like they're so [ __ ]
intricate and a lot of it there is like
a little bit of or kind of early cgi
because like i said this was 1995.
uh not all of it looks all that great uh
you know it's kind of rough because it
was a long time ago and uh you know i
don't know how much money they had to
spend on this movie but a lot of the
effects are practical and the set design
and stuff like that is just uh
incredible so kind of overlook like a
little bit like there's toward the end
there's like an explosion that doesn't
really look that good and [ __ ] like that
but you know like i said it's you can
overlook it because the whole look of it
is just so crazy and imaginative so this
old guy lives he lives in his lair thing
with
a little person
woman
named martha
and she has like this really big hair
that's
it's something
he also has all of these
clones
uh which were also created by the
scientist now you don't know where the
scientist is until the end of the movie
but he's just like disappeared
so there's also there's these clones
that are kind of like
the they're sort of like childlike and
they're always kind of like arguing over
which one was the original like you know
what i'm they're trying to pull rank on
one another
uh oh and also
there's uncle irvin
who is a brain in a fish tank who can
talk
and he has this little thing like he's
in his tank
and he has this little thing that comes
out like almost like a little eye it
looks like a weird like old-fashioned
camera type thing and it comes out on
you have to like [ __ ] see
the set design and the [ __ ] visuals
on this to believe it they're like
[ __ ] amazing
okay so because cronk
can't dream
he decides what he's gonna do is he's
gonna start
kidding a little indirectly kidnapping
kids and putting them in this
contraption that he's invented
that
extracts their dreams okay so they we
have that going on
how he gets the kids he doesn't want to
go out and get his hands dirty and like
go kidnap the kids himself
but where he gets them from
is in this port city that's near where
his lair is
there's this
cult of cyborgs
called cyclops and they're called
cyclops because they're blind uh but
they have these sort of like things that
stick in their eyes that actually i
think cronk makes for them
and they can kind of see in that green
like i said it's very fallout if you
played fallout and then you see this
movie you'll be like oh yeah that's
where they got the idea for this that
and the other and they they totally did
they they admitted that that as much
that this was a big influence on how on
the look of the fallout game
so these cyclops uh like i said they
kind of see everything in like the green
uh type of you know tv analog tv looking
thing
so
they basically
kidnap the kids in exchange for all the
gear and stuff that cronk makes for them
now near the beginning of the movie
there's one little boy named don ree
and he is kidnapped now don ree
is the little a brother he's not like
the biological little brother but he's
like the adopted little brother
of ron pearlman's character ron pearlman
is named one
and he is a circus strong man so you
meet him at the beginning they wrap
chains around him and he busts them open
and stuff he looks great in this by the
way it's like they have this weird
kind of reddish
howdy doody kind of is it kind of howdy
duty hair i guess it's like really
really short that it's kind of poofy in
the front and he's got like this really
cool sweater and [ __ ] like that but yeah
so uh so don ree gets kidnapped and
the guy who's like the carnival barker
who i guess is kind of like their dad
figure he gets mugged and he gets like
stabbed and that's how the little kid
gets kidnapped
now uh so all that's going on
and then there's also this other like
criminal syndicate
and this is run
by a pair of conjoined twins these two
women who are collectively known as the
octopus
and what they these two are creepy as
[ __ ] by the way
and they like talk together and [ __ ]
like that it's just like i don't know
it's really weird
so their whole enterprise is they have
all of these orphans
who they sort of like uh
boss around and they kind of make them
go out and steal [ __ ] so they go around
pickpocketing and all that kind of stuff
and then the kit little kids have to
come back and they take all the stuff
that the kids stole
so
what ends up happening though is that
because
one
uh decides he has to go find his little
brother don ree
he sort of cross paths crosses paths
with all of these orphans
and
one in particular this little girl named
miette who is kind of like this
uh sort of worldwide she's probably i
kind of feel like she's maybe like 10 or
11 or maybe 12 or something like that
the little girl that plays her is like
[ __ ] great by the way and i didn't
know this but again i was listening to
chat the movies and the woman that was
on there uh had grown up in new orleans
and was fairly fluent in french and she
said oh actually the name
yet is almost kind of like a nickname it
can mean either crumb like in a bad way
or it can mean like sweet little morsel
or something like that so that's kind of
why they named her the names for that
because it has kind of like two meetings
so he gets involved with this little
girl named miyette and they have this
sort of like plan
where they're gonna go rescue
don ree from the kidnappers because
they're gonna put him in
this machine and like extract his dreams
and stuff so
that's kind of so you have kind of like
those three threads just sort of like
going in but just me saying that and i
know it sounds like crazy and like i
said like i'm tripping balls but that is
totally what happens in the movie and
there's just like all kind of [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ]
ensues the tone of this is very very
weird like i said it's kind of like
it's
a science fantasy
it's surrealist it's funny like it has
some
sort of slap sticky kind of not overtly
well i guess some of it kind of is it's
not like overtly slapstick but it does
have some of that kind of like humor in
it but then it has like some real
disturbing [ __ ] too like there's one
thing oh i also forgot to mention that
there's also a guy who has
uh fleas he has like hypo not like on
him but he has like he's you know the
circus kind of thing where he has like
fleas but these fleas are like super
intelligent
and he can give them
this little drug that causes aggression
and so he can send these trained fleas
out like to bite people and then when
they bite people those people start like
acting really crazy and aggressive
so at one point in the movie which i
don't they would never show this in
american movie i don't think but um
there's one point in the movie where
they send the fleas after one
uh you know ron perlman's character the
fleas bite him and he goes super
aggressive and he starts beating the
[ __ ] out of like the little kid the his
little friend like miyette so there's
that so there is like really disturbing
[ __ ] too and like some of the kids like
because some of the stuff is like they
have all this dream imagery like some of
the kids that are having nightmares
while they're being extracted like in
the machine
and there's one like toward the end
that's like super creepy with all these
like really weird santa clauses and [ __ ]
like that and it's like i don't know
there's there's this whole thing about
cronk the older uh the older guy that's
extracting the dreams and how him coming
to the realization
that the reason the kids are having all
these nightmares is because of him he's
like the monster like that didn't really
occur to him before and he's like a
really really scary dude so yeah just
the visuals in this just
veer wildly toward but it's but it works
somehow like because it's so fantastical
because there's really nothing realistic
about it at all it's just kind of its
own like self-contained world
that you can kind of have this sort of
like slap sticky sort of humor
especially like with all
with the clone brothers uh they do like
some really
some really crazy because they're like
really really childlike you know i mean
even though they're grown dudes and it's
all the same guy obviously but they did
it like digitally
and so he does like real kind of like
like slap sticky stuff but there's other
kind of stuff like that too like with
the little kid orphans like you know
getting one over on the people chasing
them and stuff like that but there's
just all kind of these crazy little
touches like hey let's get this key from
somewhere and i know the best way to do
it we'll get a mouse and we'll tie a
magnet to its tail and then like have it
go in the thing where the key is and
then the magnet will pick up the key and
then we drop a cat in there
it's just very uh
you know everything looks like a rube
goldberg type of device like i said so
you have this kind of like steampunky
absurdist
uh kind of vibe to it which is actually
like really entertaining and as i said
yes the plot is complicated uh to a
point where
as i said you have all these kind of
criminal uh elements going on you have
all these little kids who are
technically criminals too uh because
they're kind of street urchins but
they're sort of being made to do it
and
so you and you have all that and then
later on you find out what happened to
the vanished scientists like the
scientists who made uh you know cronk
and the uh and the other clone brothers
and the brain and you know uncle urban
and the jar and all that other kind of
stuff so you find out what happens to
him and then there's just kind of like
all this [ __ ] chaos going on
uh you know while they're looking for
but the through line of it really
uh the heart of the movie is
ron perlman's character one looking for
his little adopted brother don ree and
his friendship with miyette
interestingly i didn't really um this
didn't super occur to me and i'm sure it
didn't occur to me at the time it maybe
would bother people more nowadays
although maybe not
i kind of feel like there was a little
bit of
rumble about this that they thought that
the relationship between
one and miette
was
a little weird because like obviously
she's a little kid and he's like a grown
adult
but
honestly it does because there is one
scene in there where they're kind of
like you know she's helping him like
find his little brother and everything
like that there is one scene where he's
like blowing on her back like i'm being
a radiator and uh you know keeping her
warm or whatever and she does say
something about oh he needs to find a
wife and it's almost kind of like
implied that they have kind of like i
don't want to say it's implied they have
a romance because it's not like that at
all but it doesn't really i don't know
in the movie it doesn't really come
across like that i guess because ron
perlman's character he's very
i don't i don't necessarily he's kind of
childlike in a way you know what i mean
he doesn't talk a lot he's very
sweet he's very gentle he's very he
almost comes across as like
frankenstein's monster a little bit just
because he's so large and he doesn't
really talk all that much and he seems
kind of out of place among all of these
other people because most of the other
people in this are
kind of uh terrible you know what i mean
or they're you know they're monstrous in
their own ways whereas he's very much
like a gentle giant type of character so
you don't really get any kind of
creepy vibe or at least i didn't
um but i know that like a couple people
did maybe complain about that like they
thought it was a little bit weird like a
couple of the conversations that they
had but to be honest it didn't really
come across like that to me at all i
mean he just doesn't really seem like
creepy in the slightest he just seems
like a sweet like i said a gentle giant
type of character and he even says to me
at one point that he kind of sees her
like a little sister and like because he
had a little brother who was a little
bit younger than her and the whole
inciting incident was his little brother
being kidnapped and him
you know and one having to like deal
with all of this criminal element like
in order to find him so i kind of got
more of that kind of vibe where he was
just kind of like oh you're like a
little kid like my little brother is so
i just kind of felt like it was like
that but you know i don't know if other
people feel differently about it it just
didn't really uh seem all that weird or
creepy to me at all
so yeah so
if you have not seen
uh this movie and as i said if you're
really into like really weird surrealist
kind of [ __ ] particularly terry gilliam
i feel like that's probably like the
closest thing then you should probably
see this it's really really
it's really a cool like visual
experience i mean just the set design
alone
is amazing like this whole entire world
they created and it's so detailed and
there's just like all of this stuff like
going on in the background and it's just
like very very surrealist as i said
you don't necessarily have to quote
unquote understand it or it's not really
that hard to follow as long as you're
kind of paying attention there's a lot
of stuff going on and there's a lot of
overlapping stories but i didn't really
find it that
complicated to follow
as long as you're kind of like paying
attention but honestly
yeah it helps to like pay attention to
what's going on but you don't even have
to do that it's just it's such a visual
treat
that
you don't really need to like keep
up that much with what's going on to
like really appreciate it because i kind
of feel like the visuals are sort of
like the star of the show but that's not
to say that you know the the plot should
be given short shrift or anything like
that because it is like a really good
interesting story that actually does
have
a lot of stuff to say about
um growing older like losing your dreams
losing your hopes things like that so it
does have like a deeper theme behind it
but if you don't want to take that away
from it you don't have to i mean you can
just like watch it as like a beautiful
piece of art and just kind of like leave
it at that so if you've seen it if
you've seen their other two uh or their
other kind of like popular movies
delicatessen or emily i don't think i've
seen delicatessen yet i have seen emily
though a couple of times um so let me
know like what you
feel about it if you've seen this movie
if you remember it if you wanna if you
saw it a long time ago and forgot about
it and want to see it again i'd be
interested to know what everybody thinks
about city of lost children from 1995 so
let me know in the comments what your
feelings are and that will do it for
this flickers of fear i will see you
guys on the next one bye